[Music]
hi hi my name is stina s and I work as
Chief of Staff or head of cabinet as we
call it in the commission for the
Executive Vice President M Vester who's
responsible for preparing Europe for a
digital age but also competition
[Music]
commissioner what I like in the work in
the commission is really working with
people from all over Europe having
colleagues from Romania from Bulgaria
from Finland from Sweden from France all
over Europe which gives us an insight
into how other people think as well and
then the second thing is that all of the
work that we do here in the commission
should have a positive impact for all of
the European citizens and that is really
very
[Music]
rewarding what I like about the
commission as an employer is first of
all that you have uh all the benefits
that you can expect from a public
employer uh but you also have the
possibilities to grow throughout your
career I've worked in in in energy I've
worked in environment I've worked on
human resources files I've worked on
Development Corporation and right now
I'm working on making Europe fit for the
digital age but then also competition
and so that means you can grow
throughout your career uh in all of
these areas and you can as well learn a
lot of different languages so both the
the social side of things but then also
the career side of things I think the
commission is one of the best employers
you can
[Music]
imagine